when working in space you must be as
efficient as possible you cannot waste
any resources not because you care about
i mean obviously you care about the
environment but that's not the main
reasons because you can imagine that if
we're going to emit carbon dioxide on
the moon like for every uh kilogram
of carbon it's like one million dollar
wasted
welcome to 20 minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today it's a journey each one is
different unique inspiring let's get
started
[Music]
this episode is powered by j ventures a
community driven vc fund in silicon
valley in partnership with lomitek and
sponsored by homework ventures hippo
insurance opposed hillary stanford leap
and birthright excel and in media
partnership with ctec
hello and welcome to another episode of
20 minute leaders today we're talking to
jonathan geiffman co-founder and ceo of
helios
jonathan guyfund born and raised in tel
aviv israel is married to aden the
father to dean he spent nearly a decade
in the israeli armed forces and he
co-founded a product design studio that
operates in the united states and in the
past five years is pursuing a childhood
dream to enable the expansion of
humanity beyond earth with this company
helios which we're going to hear about
right now welcome jonathan jonathan
gaffman welcome to 20 minute leaders how
are you
great thank you thank you for having me
you know usually i ask where the other
where the person is calling from we know
which city which country i think here
you know the more relevant question to
this to this talk is we're both talking
from planet earth yet what you're
usually concerned with is what's
happening outside of planet earth and so
i think that's that's a much more
suitable question for this conversation
jonathan with project helios you're
working on something that i think you
know very very few people get the
privilege to entertain themselves with
these questions in the day-to-day you're
really thinking about the future you're
thinking about
you know the the greater perspectives of
what needs to happen you know with
humanity and what's happening around the
galaxy above us and and around us and
i'm excited to understand a little bit
better you know where this comes from
and what project helios really is about
so maybe we can get started a little bit
with you and tell me you know a little
bit about your background and how you
found yourself asking the question of
space
yes so actually my official background
is nothing to do with space which to be
honest yeah yeah i spent nearly a decade
in the israeli defense
forces and armed forces
um but space was always a passion of
mine in general
and uh just to give an example my
grandmother
uh died
two months ago less than two months ago
and after i mean we
needed to evacuate their apartment and
everything in uh my aunt she found
a drawing that i made made when i was
six
it was a drawing of like a very small
earth a bigger moon and like rockets and
astronauts and everything so you can see
from
early on yes that was a real passion of
mine and about five years ago
yes about five years ago i decided uh
to pursue
uh this passion
and uh i had this
i don't know you can you can say it's a
crazy idea of uh
looking into
what technologies
are
missing or required
in order for humanity
to be able to establish permanent
infrastructure on the moon mars and
eventually beyond
so yeah this is how it is
sounds like a it sounds like it's a very
simple mission statement but you know
where where does this so take me a
little bit through the pain problem you
know just like with any traditional
pitch you know why why is this even a
question that is relevant to be asked
and why is now you know as we approach
2022 why is this the right time to be
asking this question
yeah actually if if you were asking this
about five years ago it would be harder
for me to answer but today it's easier
because there is a lot of hype around
the space industry in general and in
business right last two years three
years there's a lot of movement a lot of
drive
to go back to the moon
we see it
with nasa's artemis program uh
collaborating with additional
12 space agencies from different
countries
and this time in
opposed to what was
uh 50 years ago when they just you know
planted a flag in
uh went back to earth
this time uh the goal is to establish
a permanent
base a permanent infrastructure so we
can have a continuous
astronaut presence on the moon just by
the way like we have continuous
astronaut presence in the international
space station for more than 20 years now
straight
so it's the same concept just to do this
on the moon now one of the main
challenges of doing this
is the extraordinary cost of sending
anything from earth to the moon i mean
today it is
quoted at more than like a million
dollars per kilogram
good for two pounds wow that's you can
imagine yeah that's that's very
expensive and you can imagine that like
a permanent base will weigh
a lot i mean probably hundreds of tons
and that is just a permanent
infrastructure then you have consumables
that you need like to replenish and you
need all the time
and then
we realize when digging into this uh
that the most sought after consumable by
far by a lot is going to be oxygen
and not to breathe
not not for breathing breathing is
peanuts
but as part of the rocket propellant
okay and just to give you
yes an idea like a sense of how much
oxygen is needed
uh because this is quite mind-boggling
even even for people from the space
industry most don't really know this
only people usually actually deal with
rockets and rocket engines nodes
but
like if you take starship okay spacex's
flagship project
and uh
in this case according to the known data
today
when it is fully loaded only in the
upper part the part that will land on
the moon and mars etc when fully loaded
with the weight of the vehicle itself
cargo astronauts propellant everything
it is
expected to to weigh something like 1400
tons
out wow out of that weight
nearly a thousand tons is just oxygen
to burn
the propellant it's like something like
900 tons i thought so it's like 65 of
the total mass something like that
and this ratio is interesting yes it's
pretty much uh true to any other space
vehicle
that will be involved in these uh
endeavors
and uh yes so there's no way around it
if we want to make this whole project as
i mean as humanity want to make this
sustainable and
actually do it in the long run and be
able then to go onward to mars etc
we must be able to produce that oxygen
to source it
on site
on the moon or
on mars
etc
um yeah so so this is like the why why
to do this
so now that the questions times first of
all i think that an important question
that i want to know is how come i
haven't heard about this yet right i
mean i i consider myself you know i i
listen to things i'm also interested in
space is this something that is like
really well known around the world or is
this an or is this something that you
know only
few people are really digging their
nails into because i'm trying to figure
out also if this is such a huge problem
why aren't we seeing headlines about
this and seeing a bunch of companies
trying to go and tackle it
no so there are a bunch of companies
that going about and trying to tackle it
around the world mainly in the us
uh but uh you're right i mean it's in
the beginning where in the beginning
uh the main issues
uh today are
to get to the moon uh that's like the
first set so you have the launchers uh
then you have the lunar landers you need
communication you need energy you need a
lot of a lot of stuff
and as we see it
some of these technologies that they may
i just mentioned are not fully matured
yet but they are about to be and they're
well-funded companies that are pursuing
them and the next step that is not
uh as we think sufficiently uh uh
pursued
is the technologies
it's not only our technology it's like a
whole range of technologies that revolve
uh extraction utilization storage usage
of resources on site
and uh there is there is like a it's
like a sub
it's a niche industry in the space
industry
that's uh nasa calls them
i mean nasa calls that area uh isru
in situ resource utilization i guess
that in a furious it will be a
well-known acronym but today is only the
beginning
and yeah so you're right uh
you should have been heard about it
but
we're not there yet
well so tell me tell me about project
helios and and what is actually you know
tangibly happening there you've been
there for a few years now
we're running this organization company
tell me a little bit about you know the
vision where you see yourself and and
where you're at now
yes so our vision
is not only for space
uh we realized this early on that
several things first
that this is uh this is a marathon it's
a life it's a long road uh
to get to commercialization
and we don't want to rely on government
grants which currently we work with or
investors money which we all also work
with today uh but we don't want to rely
on these for in the long run because it
might take 10 years it might take more
even if we do everything perfectly and
our technology is amazing and works and
everything
even then
in order to commercialize this
technology we need someone to actually
buy that oxygen we need uh
to have like uh communication
services to earth excavation storage
energy like a whole set a whole value
chain
of technologies need to come to
uh
to be realized you know in the future
just for our a little link in that chain
to be profitable
so it's a long road and realize that if
we want
to make it happen we must
be able to create a sustainable
business in the shorter term
and uh here comes like how do you
utilize
these technologies here on earth okay
way before you're going to do them in
space on the moon or mars
and then it struck us that
yeah that these these technologies in
general uh to uh utilize resources in
space might have
a tremendous uh effect here on earth in
terms of the environment
because
by nature when working in space you must
be as efficient as possible you cannot
waste any resources
not because you care about i mean
obviously you care about the environment
but that's not the main reasons because
you can imagine that if we're going to
emit
carbon dioxide on the moon like for
every
uh kilogram
of carbon it's like one million dollar
wasted because we had to bring that
kilogram from earth
so uh
the way i mean this
the trajectory of these technologies is
to be extremely efficient
no waste
so
yeah so this is part of our vision as
well i mean to create a sustainable
human life
on earth
and beyond and it's also part of our of
our developments of our technologies
so from what i'm understanding you're
mainly right now working on utilizing
these resources here on earth but but a
similar technology can then be used to
extract and utilize those resources in
space correct
yes yes
so there are two main projects that we
have currently that we're working on and
i mean the first one actually we
haven't uh
made it public yet so i'll i'll make it
public now
um
is that first i mean the first project
is uh to use technologies uh these
technologies on the womb to produce
oxygen from the lunar soil okay or as we
call it lunar regolith regal is like the
more professional broader term for soil
sand loose gravel and everything
the lunar regolith is
made of over 40 oxygen by mass that
oxygen is chemically connected to
minerals and oxides and we have a
process that know how to separate it
without using consumables carbon and
stuff like that
and the other project that is derived
from uh from this
our research is to produce iron and
steel
here on earth for earth i mean for the
steel industry in a manner that is uh
more energy efficient
and with zero uh direct carbon emissions
okay that is that's actually pretty big
because the steel industry is one of the
most pollutive
and carbon emitting industries in the
world by far sure it's like uh nearly 10
of all worldwide carbon emissions is
just from the steel industry
uh and finding an alternative method to
produce steel
with
uh
less carbon emissions or even maybe zero
carbon emissions
uh then that's that's like a big it's a
big issue
and this is something we're pursuing as
well and that's actually it's a it's uh
we just about two months ago started
working on a dialogue with the steel
industry
at the moment where
hopefully this something will be able to
you know give more details about in the
coming months but it's very exciting
incredible so
you know what how do you as a leader
then you know think through
such a great vision because on one hand
you're balancing both the research and
development here on earth at the same
time you're also having to think about
okay what is how is space exploration
going to change what kind of
partnerships you have to do what kind of
you know different bodies that are large
and bureaucratic you have to start
communicating with so that you can start
planning you know a few years down the
line this is not you know a design
partnership for for a few months right
you actually have to think you know
really long term how do you go and think
about that yourself
yeah even though i'm not an engineer
um
you know in uh like officially uh i i
think i mean i think that the way we
approach it is
thinking of it as like an engineering
problem okay
it's uh it's something it's a challenge
it's something that we want to
accomplish okay technology we want to
deploy
or a business model we want to achieve
and it has many different interfaces
okay technologically with other
companies uh regulation
legal issues
um
financing and you know it just like
dissecting in
this problem into different uh
to its different aspects and different
issues and try to solve everything and
do it as
simplified as possible that's also an
important
aspect to try and simplify i mean this
it might sound complicated already so uh
i would try to simplify everything
simplified processes not only
technologically but in general
right now on our aspect and i'll quote
elon musk now
uh the best process
is no process and the best design is no
design i mean if you can simplify and
eliminate
unnecessary uh parts that's that's
better
that's their approach so take me back a
little bit a little bit to your
childhood you know looking back you know
what really were you fascinated by as a
kid
and you know if you had to look back in
elementary middle school what really got
you going
how things work
that's it yes in fact after summit i
mean my mother she was
mad at me a lot i mean she wasn't mad at
me but i was i used to
like disassemble everything at home
uh since i was very little
and uh trying to reassemble them not
always successfully
um
like every home appliance you can think
of from the vacuum cleaner to the
television
um
and trying to understand how things
works that's
fascinated me back then and also today
just i don't know
i'm like i'm really bothered if i don't
understand how something works
i i love it and so if today obviously
you know it i i'm sure that it's not
hard to gain inspiration from
from from you know the vertical that
you're in but where do you where do you
personally you know get your inspiration
in the day-to-day uh whether
professionally or or personally
um well from
many different
directions
science fiction
i have
several you know
podcasts that i really like to listen to
you know one i i'd even call him a role
model it's probably i mean i have many
role models uh you know from the obvious
ones like i don't know elon musk and uh
um
maybe uh peter thiel and uh
and more but uh
maybe the less conventional ones would
be even joe rogan
which uh i'm really fascinated how he
uh
you know absorbs new ideas and oh has
such an open mind
to all kind of different voices
it's also an inspiration
um also from my son
uh who is a one and a half years old
and uh
just you know just the thought of what
he will have in the future
what will be in the future for him that
excites me and uh
so it's also
amazing
and if i had to ask you for a few words
that you would use to describe yourself
yeah what would those be
um
wow that would be hard
or the first thing that comes to mind
that would be
unflappable
um
it's really hard to to annoy me like
like you you need to try really hard uh
so i'm pretty uncomfortable
um
maybe creative i can definitely see that
and uh
driven i'm very driven
um like helios is going to work
ellis is going to work i love it i loved
it
thank you for the time and and for the
for the amazing insights and
you know this conversation just makes
you want to go and dive way deeper into
what you're doing and
and understand this sure in this whole
world a little bit better and and i and
you know the statistics that you even
mentioned in the beginning just you know
blew my mind and i keep thinking through
you know the inefficiencies that are
there and the amazing opportunities
there is for innovation and both from a
green tech place but also just from a
financial place to allow for more space
exploration and to democratize it so
thank you very very much and stay safe
and stay healthy thank you for
everything
[Music]
you